how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and it's a great time
to be a marvel fan right now
as disney and marvel have dropped a ton
of new content including trailers and
one for the falcon and the winter
soldier there's about two minutes of
awesomeness so let's go ahead and dive
right into it we open on a tribute to
captain america
we know that some stuff for captain
america was already in a museum in
previous films but this looks like he
may have gotten his own museum now in
the marvel cinematic universe it shows
us a bunch of old promotions for captain
america
and the army it then shows sam sitting
by himself in what appears to be the
same place
looking at captain shield now sam is
dressed up in a nice
suit and tie and the last time we left
sam steve
named him the new captain america and he
gave him the shield
but as we've expected for a while it
doesn't look like that was steve rogers
choice
as the shield is locked up and it
appears that sam may be dressed to talk
to the people who
are in charge but it seems like things
may be just a little bit more
complicated than we thought we cut to
the next scene where sam is talking to
bucky and he says
the legacy of that shield is complicated
now in captain america the first avenger
they didn't reveal any of the past
of captain america shield but it
actually does have a past and what sam
is referring to
is isaiah bradley the first black
captain america
and what he's referring to is the comic
story line truth
red white and black in the storyline it
was revealed that the us government
committed secret
super soldier experiments on black
soldiers during the second world war now
we haven't heard anything about isaiah
bradley or the
secret experiments in the mcu yet but it
wouldn't be that hard
for them to ret condom into the
storyline and the storyline would
definitely make it more personal to sam
but the biggest takeaway at this point
is it seems like sam
isn't using the shield which of course
we'll go on to find out but
perhaps maybe sam chose to not use the
shield
maybe because of these experiments that
were conducted in the past he may have
fear or he may simply just not want to
because of the past
we then go to a convoy of vehicles in
which we have no idea who's inside but
we do know that seemingly this terrorist
organization that is introduced in this
trailer is going to eventually attack
them
as we go through the next couple of
scenes we hear the words from
bucky saying the world is upside down
and as we hear this we see
a very very big scene we see the falcon
the winter soldier and
zemo in a new city which we assume to be
madrapore now this is really huge
because if this is indeed
magipore it has a huge connection to not
only the x-men and mutants but to
wolverine specifically and
viper now in the comics viper is the
ruler of madrapore
viper would eventually take on the name
madame hydra
being a part of hydra's inner circle now
viper has tried to achieve
world domination a few times but has
usually been defeated by captain america
in which in this case now in the mcu
would technically according to steve
rogers be sam
which would explain why they are in
madrapore they are looking for viper
because she may
be behind all the terrorist attacks that
we see in this trailer
but viper is also very notably known for
marrying
logan the wolverine as i mentioned
magipore has a very big connection to
the x-men and specifically wolverine so
this
could very well be the introduction to
the mutants in the mcu but very
specifically
wolverine there have been a lot of
rumors in the past especially concerning
wolverine and his introduction in the
falcon and the winter soldier
so we'll just have to wait and see on
that now bucky and sam
are with zemo you can see him in a
couple of scenes but if you blink you'll
miss him so they have actually either
contacted him or he has contacted them
both probably seeking the same cause
taking down this organization
so they're now working with zemo but
more on that in just a little bit
we go on to the next few scenes where it
seems like there are a bunch of
terrorist attacks happening we see a
bunch of policemen or
soldiers in one scene and on their chest
is the word
justice now justice is german now there
are plenty of connections to germany and
the mcu the sokovia accords were
actually signed in germany so as far as
why some things would happen in germany
there are plenty of reasons but why
specifically is unknown at this point by
the trailer we then see some
terrorist attacks and we are introduced
to the group the flag smashers
these are the people wearing the mask
with the handprint over the mask
now although nothing is revealed about
this woman that we see in the trailer
she very well
could be madame hydra she does seem like
she is in charge of this group
and throughout the trailer they are
performing many different terrorist
attacks her actual identity is not
revealed but i would not be surprised
one bit if she actually is
viper madame hydra we go on to hear
bucky say
the world is upside down and then we get
an actual release it says this
march we then go to a scene with sam and
bucky on
sam's family ship we can see in the
background of this scene where he has
the suitcase the sign in the back says
wilson's family seafood
so wherever they're going they have the
help of sam's family now as far as the
briefcase is concerned
it looks like sam is now carrying his
wings in the suitcase this is very much
like iron man and iron man 2 how he
carried his suit in his suitcase
in fact this may even be stark
technology that we're seeing here
although we'll have to wait till the
show starts to officially find out
now the next shot is pretty cool it's a
bucky talking to sam and he says the
people need something to get behind
and it's probably a very emotional time
for him because that's who his best
friend
steve rogers the old captain america was
he was a symbol to the people
and during a time of uncertainty after
avengers in-game and during a time where
there's a bunch of terrorist attacks it
seems
the people are definitely going to need
somebody to get behind and it looks like
bucky is encouraging sam to be that
person to be that symbol of hope
we then get our first official look at
falcon
suit it's kind of blurry in the scene
but we can see the new design
and it doesn't seem like he's taken on
the mantle at this point of captain
america but if we take a look at this
next clip of sam
shaking his head he looks rather
emotional as he's doing this
and this is no doubt sam's nodding and
agreeing with bucky
when he said that the people need
something to get behind we then have a
scene where they very clearly show baron
zemo
in this scene we see zemo grieving his
family but perhaps he's not as vengeful
as he was before
as we know and as we've seen in this
trailer he will be working with sam and
bucky and of course we've seen this shot
before which is bucky's arm
dropping bullets in front of zemo which
is a scene that we're kind of unsure
about right now but many people believe
it to be
bucky letting go dropping the bullets
not killing zemo but forgiving him
we then see the new captain america not
sam but u.s
agent john walker running on the
football field now as he runs on the
field and they show the new captain
america symbol we hear bucky's words
they need a symbol talking about the
people now this implies what we kind of
knew all along us agent john walker
isn't exactly the best person and has
ulterior motives of being captain
america whether he's being brainwashed
by somebody like thunderbolt ross or
perhaps even hydra
or perhaps he's even doing it on his own
we know that he's not going
to remain captain america because he's
going to be a little bit corrupt which
is why bucky says that sam
needs to be that symbol we then see the
falcon and the winter soldier in
action sam of course is flying and doing
some pretty awesome stunts but bucky now
has a motorcycle
and this might be bucky's thing in the
series the falcon can fly he has his
wings and bucky may have a motorcycle
most of the time to keep up which is
pretty awesome and hopefully makes for
some really awesome scenes
we again run into the flag smashers but
specifically the same girl from before
we then have a bunch of more action
sequences but then we get this really
awesome clip of sam kicking this woman
just
like captain america steve rogers used
to kick people so there's definitely
going to be a lot of callbacks to chris
evans as steve rogers
now all throughout this trailer it looks
like the flag smashers are the ones
responsible for these terrorist attacks
and this heist
and throughout the trailer sam and bucky
are trying to stop them but in the scene
where we have sam and bucky in a plane
and bucky asks what the plan is and
there is no plan according to sam
because he just jumps out the plane
but we can see that there is a u.s
soldier on board
so at one point in time it looks like
they're going to have the backing of the
us army on their side
either that or a lot of people are still
very loyal to captain america so they
want to help out sam and bucky
but in a time of terror it would make
sense that the government would hire two
avengers who helped the world in
avengers infinity war and avengers
in-game
despite their past we then cut to an
amazing scene with a helicopter chasing
sam
firing at him and sam maneuvering his
way through canyons avoiding getting hit
by these missiles and it looks
absolutely fantastic super action-packed
and if this is a preview of what the
show is going to be like it is going to
be amazing
now we end on kind of a funny note some
bickering between sam
and bucky showing that their
relationship is going to be very very
tight but it's also going to be very
comedic
both best friends of steve rogers now
coming together in a very love-hate
relationship so that's it for my
breakdown of the falcon and the winter
soldier official trailer if there are
any easter eggs that you may have
spotted be sure to let me know in the
comments down below
or if you have any theories of yourself
about any part of the trailer let me
know
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
so you can stay up to date on all things
relating to the mcu and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a tony stark
quantum suit funko pop provided by
heroes hideout.com
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof